welcome back to my collaboration with
the schmoes we're gonna be talking about
Batman and Robin today yes we are
my name is freeze and it well was the
chilling sound of you two
this is the way the world could add it
I'm gonna do is I'm going to show you
the entirety of my review first and
close that with the schmoes review of
Batman and Robin Batman and Robin is a
cinematic atrocity it really is a
terrible movie it's one of the worst
movies ever made and we all know it
sucks so I was just thinking you know
what let's have some fun with this movie
honestly if you sit down to view this
movie as a comedy it is like it's gold
it's comedic gold this is such a funny
movie because it is so horrible
everything went wrong with this movie I
mean it's not even worth talking about
the plot really Batman Forever had some
success financially and it was like they
gave Joel Schumacher free rein to do
whatever he wanted and this is what we
got one of the first things you see in
the movie is this no better way to start
a movie than some bet but in your face
George Clooney is Batman George
Clooney's a terrific actor he's proved
that since this movie he's apologized
for this movie publicly that is saying
something when an actor publicly
apologizes for a movie when Michael
Keaton came in as Batman and he grabbed
a guy and he said I'm Batman it was
powerful you know the other actors had
their various ways of saying it let's
look through that but you know what
let's look through the various ways
actors have introduced themselves as
Batman and then let's look how Clooney
did it first we got Michael Keaton I'm
Batman now let's look at Kevin Conroy
the voice from the animated series
the night all right now val kilmer you
see on most Bruce Wayne and Batman not
because I have to be now because I
choose to be Christian Bale I'm Batman
and now George Clooney v freeze I'm
Batman
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait a second that looked extremely
familiar to me what does that remind me
of
[Music]
oh man Arnold Schwarzenegger the lines
in this movie the Robin you know all the
close-ups of the the butt in the crotch
and the zooms and everything was just so
terrible in this movie Bane is in this
movie and what do I remember most about
him
bombs everything about this movie fails
on every possible level Batman and Robin
is one of the worst movies ever made it
is however hilarious I introduced a new
word to you this movie is a hilarious
'ti it is such an atrocity that it is
hilarious
Batman and Robin gets an F from me
however if you view this movie as a
comedy on the hilarious ''tis scale it's
an a-plus all right now over the schmoes
for their review of Batman and Robin
hey everybody over at Chris Stefan's
channel we honor the schmoes very happy
to see it even though we're talking
about garbage we're talking Batman and
Robin ladies and gentlemen the second
Joel Schumacher movie the fourth one in
this series the word doing on Batman
reviews and I think it's safe to say
this one is the suckiest of the bunch
yeah we are not gonna pull any punches
this is a piss pile on wheels
Backman will watch his beloved Gotham
perish but left boys there's a storm
coming into this movie tried to jump
over the shark the shark moved out of
the way and said get the hell out sharks
just like this go ahead go ahead yeah
well the first thing people think of
when they think is oh my goodness I
my pants because that's the kind of
smell that happens when you think about
how bad this movie so how do you feel
about the film's Thanks this came out in
the late 90s and after Batman Forever
which is even for what's a successful
movie I we didn't love it but it made
money and this one by the time this
movie came out I was already done with
the Batman franchise it was run into the
ground
I've never seen this movie on a whim two
weeks after it had already come out that
shouldn't be that way for a boy who
loves bats I wasn't done with it yet
because I drank the kool-aid of Batman
Forever back then so I was excited to
see what happened then they said oh you
know what George Clooney's gonna play
Bruce Wayne's you know you could pull
any fan the guy for me Ark that works
and then we're gonna bring more villain
villains in we do the multi villains
okay well maybe that including one very
special villain yeah they said they're
gonna bring Arnold back and the great
Arnold as a villain again I mean he's
probably the best villain of all time in
Terminator I'm one of the best and you
pulled off the sunglasses can he pull up
being mr. freeze no I don't want pulled
off anything nobody could pull off
changing into their underwear in this
movie I mean it is so bad everything
that literally anything anyone does is
this movie to be chastised to say never
do that in film because that's terrible
Batman watch Batman Robin improve that
sauce you know when you're watching a
really bad movie and you want to leave
the theater i watch this in my apartment
last week and i wanted to just walk it
stand in traffic for a while it's so
awful to watch
[Music]
Eggar
it starts out bad and it gets worse
alfred in this movie is like dude I
gotta quit and go to Florida this sucks
I turned on Batman and Robin with with
my dad and he punched me in the face
then I apologize there's so many things
this with like baby like Arnold is so
bad he has no idea what he's doing like
within 5 minutes in this movie they're
ice skating and playing hockey with
Arnold it's pretty much just how many
bad one-liners can we get out
all right everybody chill you gonna get
iced you do this chill out
come on put it on ice can you carefully
it's cold
ok Arnold Arnold down Arnold bein also
makes an appearance you want to call in
vain it it's not really bad it's a dude
who lifts weights who wears a mask
that's the where the similarities end
call him pain but he's just a mindless
brute has none of the characteristics
that Bane has and then you have Alicia
Silverstone Batgirl
Batgirl you are that's not like PC what
about that person
the Batcave knows what we are for just
two killings and then a god bless
outbreak for being in this movie I mean
that he signed on he look everyone
signing his contract like Chris no
Donald's Robin you know and to George
Clooney's to George Clooney's credit he
still owns he's like yeah I was in
Batman Fred here's how bad Batman Robin
is George Clooney was also in attack of
the killer tomatoes and the bad movie
that everybody goes to at George Clooney
is Batman and Robin that's how bad it is
kids everyone involved in this movie
apologizes for it when they go to
restaurant and they sit down only this
isn't a I'm sorry for Batman Robin don't
spit in my food so many bad lines I mean
at one point George Clooney says to yeah
well this is why Superman works alone
shut up this is why Superman works alone
and then what else is up this crap they
say this bat credit card bad ass bat
nipples
why bad ass I don't want to think about
anything more with this movie so I'm
just gonna show it and I'm gonna give
this movie a point five schmoes out of
five here's why I'm also gonna give it
half a badass I'll get point five out of
five and here's why because that point
five had this shitbox never come out
then everyone would about all the
franchise is dead and when Nolan
rebooted it everyone's like think P I
have a feeling this is what people talk
about at AAA meetings which I'll
probably have to go to eventually is
this is what you call rock bottom this
is what you say when I mean I had bat
nipples and there was a badass at one
point there was mr. freeze involved but
then I found salvation and his name is
Christopher Nolan thank you sir
it was a little my master plan after you
mean the would Batman movie ever because
I got thinking like a governor if that
happens then they have to reboot it
IRL boy gets a made he pledged I got an
acting job Oscar
alright so that's all thank goodness for
the Joel Schumacher Batman movies we're
gonna have Batman Begins on our channel
we're gonna go back to Chris documents
channel which we're currently hanging
out in for the Dark Knight and then
there's a new Batman movie that comes
out July 20th we've all comes together
bigger cave Batman and Robin thanks Mazz
next Monday Batman Begins on their
channel stay tuned for that and if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]